Bitte schön. Guten Abend. Ich heiße Dr. Günes. Ich bin hier,
diese Station als Assistenzarzt für Sie zuständig. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das
Annahmengespräch führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie? Ja, natürlich.
Danke schön. Wie heißen Sie denn? Mein Name ist Frank Büchler. Frank,
können Sie bitte Ihren Nachname langsam bestellen? Büchler, ich bestelle
Birberta Ü, César Heinrich, Ludwig Emil Richard, Büchler. Büchler, Herr Büchler.
Also, wie heißen Sie denn? Ich bin 64 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. März 1960. Herr Büchler, wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin ungefähr 1,73. Und wie
sind Sie? Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit? Oh je, ich glaube, ich habe etwas zugenommen. Das dürfen
Sie so 97 kg sein. 20 kg. Okay. Was bittigst du zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Als ich habe
es halt schon Wochen, Rückenschmerzen, aber seit jetzt einigen Tagen habe ich hier
von an der rechten Brust so Brennen, Zielen, Schmerzen, das tut richtig weh.
Okay. Seit einigen Tagen hat sich die in Ihrer Beschwerden verstärkt.
Oh ja, ganz schlimm, ich nehme Tabletten, aber das bringt nichts.
Wurden Sie schon einmal erlebt, diese Symptome oder erst einmal?
Ich habe die Symptome, ich habe die vor einigen Jahren mal ähnlich gehabt, aber das ist damals
auf der linken Seite, das war aber nicht so schlimm. Aber jetzt ist es ziemlich schlimm,
man kann die Schmerzen kaum aushalten. Vor einem Jahr, wie wurden Sie behandelt wegen der Schmerzen?
Da habe ich Schmerztabletten genommen und dann war das nach einigen Tagen weg.
Okay, welche Schmerzen haben Sie eingenommen? Ich glaube, das war die Ibuprofen, glaube ich.
Seit einer Woche haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, ich war schon mehrfach bei meinem Hausarzt und der hat mir erst einmal ging gegeben, das hat
nichts gebracht. Dann war ich nochmal und das letzte Mal hatte mir Traumadol oder ähnlich
aufgeschrieben, aber das hilft auch nichts.
Novalgin hat ihn nicht geholt. Ich möchte diese anderen Gespräche unterbrechen, Herr Büchler.
Ich möchte Ihre wichtige Parameter, zum Beispiel Ihre Puls, Ihre Atmung, Ihre Sauerstabzettigung
und Ihre Blutdruck zu überprüfen.
Ja, gerne, das wäre ganz gut, deswegen bin ich hier.
Dann machen wir weiter.
Also ich brauche irgendwas gegen die Schmerzen, ich muss arbeiten, aber es wird nicht besser,
das ist echt ganz schlimm.
Ja, ich muss sofort einen EKG beschreiben für Sie.
Und dann können wir weitergehen?
Ja, gerne, können wir weiter machen.
Herr Büchler, können Sie Ihre Beschwerden genau beschreiben?
Leiden Sie auch Engengefühl, Druckgefühl in der Brust?
Nein, das habe ich nicht. Also Luftloat habe ich jetzt nicht.
Dann laufen, da passiert nichts. Nur wenn ich mich bewege, so nach rechts links,
oder wenn ich Luft hole, eine aushat mir, dann habe ich so einen Kribbeln oder das Stächen
und das spart so ein bisschen auch in Richtung Bauch, aber es ist mehr rechts.
Ja, rechten Oberbauch, meinen Sie?
Also genau, kommt von hier unterhalb der rechten Brust und geht in Richtung rechte Oberbauch.
Sind Sie noch da, Doktor? Ich habe keine Verbindung mehr.
Okay, der Doktor ist nicht da.
Bitte.
Herr Büchler, haben Sie seit einigen Wochen, besonders seit einigen Tagen,
rechten Brustkorb, sichende und brennende Schmerzen?
Ja, genau so ist es.
Und die Haut, Richtung Bauch, da habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, das brennt ein bisschen.
Ah, okay, brennende Haut.
Haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches Farberveränderung auf dem Haut bemerkt?
Also ich habe mich im Spiegel angeschaut, dann merke ich nichts.
Ich kann aber meinen Rücken halt nicht sehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich einen Ausschlag
am Rücken habe, weil am Rücken tut es auch weh.
Ich dachte auch mal, ob es vielleicht eine Gürtelrose ist, aber
vielleicht können Sie mir das mal angucken.
Haben Sie einen Hautausschlag bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nichts gesehen, aber können Sie mir auf den Rücken mal schauen,
ob ich einen Ausschlag habe.
Okay, haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden an der Rücken, in Ihrem Rücken?
Manchmal ja, ja.
Manchmal ja.
Manchmal das Gefühl, das kommt von hinten und zieht hier über die Rippen nach vorne.
Na vorne. Okay. So wie Gültel vor mich.
Genau, deswegen hat mein Freund erst mal kurz meine Gürtelrose,
und ich dachte, vielleicht ist das auch eine Gürtelrose,
ob Sie mal nachschauen können.
Okay. Herr Büchler, fühlen Sie,
würden Sie mich kurz anschauen?
Ich ziehe meinen T-Shirt mal kurz aus.
Ja, gerne.
Ich bin da drücken, ob Sie da was sehen.
Ich kann gerne anschauen, ja, genau.
Okay, das ist ja nett, und Sie sehen keinen Ausschlag.
Ja, kein Ausschlag, okay.
Führen Sie sich Herzrasen oder Herzsturmen?
Nein, mit dem Herzen fühle ich jetzt nichts.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, fühlen Sie sich kein Luftnot?
Nein.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder müssten Sie schon erbrochen?
Erbrechen? Nein.
Nein. Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich habe schon seit einigen Jahren ein bisschen Probleme mit der Prostata,
aber da ist jetzt keine zusätzliche Problematik.
Okay. Was haben Sie genau mit der Prostata,
nachtliche Wasserlassen?
Ja, ich muss mal nachts aufstehen,
auch tagsüber öfters mal auf Toilette,
da war ich beim Urologen,
der meinte, das ist nicht schlimm,
der ist nur etwas vergrößert,
und der hat mit Tabletten aufgeschrieben.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Kompetemperatur einmal gemessen,
oder fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Ich habe jetzt keine Temperatur gemessen,
aber ich fühle mich auch nicht warm.
Nein, ich fühle mich auch nicht warm.
Ich fühle mich auch nicht warm.
Gut, schön.
Haben Sie Probleme?
Haben Sie, schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, manchmal muss ich nachts mal aufstehen,
weil ich auch Wasserlassen muss,
aber ansonsten schlafe ich gut her.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist der Appetit?
Ach, so gut.
Sie sehen ja, ich habe einen dicken Bauch.
Also, mit einem Appetit,
kann ein bisschen weniger werden.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon gesagt,
haben Sie schon etwas zugenommen?
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie schon gemessen?
Also, ich hatte gesagt, ich habe ungefähr 97 Kilo aktuell.
97 Kilo, zugenommen, meine Sie.
Nein, insgesamt habe ich 97.
97, ja, haben Sie schon gesagt.
Wie viel Kilo in der letzten Seite haben Sie zugenommen?
Ach so, zugenommen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Ich habe insgesamt viel zu viel Kilo.
Und welche Zeitraum haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, das habe ich schon in den letzten 2-3 Jahren schon.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Nachschweiß oder Stelfrost?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Gut.
Herr Büchler,
möchten Sie sonst noch etwas ergänzen,
von denen ich wissen müsste?
Also, ich möchte gerne, dass die Schmerzen weggehen.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt extra zu Ihnen gekommen
und nicht mehr zum Hausarzt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was Sie machen sollen.
Ja, und deswegen bin ich hier.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Leiden Sie unter krönchel Erkrankungen
außer Prostatavergrößerung?
Ja, ja, ich habe einiges.
Und zwar habe ich einen hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe ein Diabetes.
Ich habe ein bisschen Knieprobleme auf beiden Seiten.
Okay.
Genau, und dementsprechend nehme ich auch einige Medikamente.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen,
mit dem Blutdruck und der Blutdruck?
Die Fragen sind,
da muss ich mal meine Frau fragen.
Die Medikamentinliste, die Bereite, die man alles vor hat.
Kann ich Ihnen nachher noch mal zeigen,
mit der Medikamentinliste?
Okay, beide Untersuchungen,
vielleicht können wir anschauen.
Ja, Sie kannst damit.
Okay, gut.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Büchler?
Nein, nein, wahrscheinlich werde ich
das linke Knie operieren lassen müssen,
weil auch da die Schmerzen immer mehr zunehmen.
Okay, ich habe vergessen zu fragen,
seit wann leiden Sie
an Ihren Blutdruck und Altezucker?
Das ist schon über 15 Jahre, mehr als 10 Jahre.
Die beiden, mehr als 10 Jahre?
Ja, ja.
Seit ungefähr 2 Jahren leiden Sie
eine Prostatevergrößerung?
Ja, ja, kann man so sagen.
Und Ihre Knieschmerzen leiden Sie
ungefähr seit wann?
Das ist schon länger, fast 20 Jahre schon.
Okay. Herr Büchler, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Noch nie, bevor meinten Sie, oder?
Nein, kann man sagen, aber ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ja, schön, gut.
Trinken Sie gelegentlich oder regelmäßig Alkohol?
Auch sehr, sehr selten.
Ja, sehr selten. Was denken Sie?
Ich habe zu Berndern im Sommer vielleicht mal so ein kaltes Bier.
Okay.
Aber manchmal vielleicht ein Wein.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht folgende Fragen persönlich.
Warum Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Rohlen? Nein, nein.
Okay.
Gut. Leiden Ihre Erden
an chronische Erkrankungen, so wie Sie, Herr Büchler?
Ja, mein Vater hat auch einen hohen Blutdruck
und leidet auch zusätzlich an Parkinson.
Okay.
Er ist jetzt 85.
Meine Mutter hat auch einen hohen Blutdruck
und die hat leider eine beginnende Demenz.
Okay.
Tut mir sehr leid.
Es ist sehr unangenehmer für Ihre Familie.
Ja, das ist schon so.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Haben Sie Geschwister? Nein.
Sie sind Einzelkind.
Ja, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Schiffskapitän.
Schiffskapitän.
Ich bin in der Binnenschifffahrt.
Ja.
Ich bin Schiffskapitän und ich transportiere Ware.
Das ist ein spannender Beruf für Sie, oder?
Ja, das ist das liebe ich sehr.
Deswegen haben Sie keinen Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ach, doch, Stress gibt es viele.
Haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, es ist halt viel Arbeit.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Sind Sie verheiratet? Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder? Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Zwei Erwachsene, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, der eine ist schon 48,
ne, pardon, 38.
Und die Tochter, die ist 33.
Die beiden sind hoffentlich gesund.
Ja, ja, die haben glücklicherweise sind gesund.
Okay. Herr Büchler treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Doch, das hätte ich gerne, aber dazu habe ich leider keine Zeit.
Nein.
Keine Zeit, so treiben.
Sind Ihnen Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Also ich habe so eine Polenallergie, das ist momentan auch sehr schlimm.
Da muss ich auch manchmal Tabletten nehmen, deswegen.
Wie äußert sich Ihre Polenallergie?
Ja, ich krieg Tränen in den Augen, meine Nase läuft, ich muss immer liesen.
Okay, verstehe ich. Es ist so sehr unangenehm für Sie.
Oh ja, genau.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit ausländisch gewesen, Herr Büchler?
Nein, nein.
Ich bin überwiegend in Deutschland.
Okay, sind Sie vorständig geimpft wegen Corona?
Ja, da hat mein Hausarzt nochmal geschaut.
Ich hatte vor einem halben Jahr nochmal einige Impfungen bekommen.
Mein Tät sind die Impfungen komplett.
Ja, wie schön. Herr Büchler.
Wir sind fast fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich, Herr Büchler?
Nein, vielen Dank.
Ich möchte, dass Sie mir eine Lösung anbieten und vielleicht etwas geben können,
dass die Schmerzen mal endlich weggehen.
Ja, ja, verstehe ich.
Ich kann noch nicht sagen, was Sie genau haben, Herr Büchler.
Wir arbeiten hier in der Klinik, ein großes Erfahrendesthemen.
Wir müssen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Deswegen bin ich auch hierhergekommen, in der Hoffnung, dass man mir hilft.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gute Entscheidungen getroffen.
Die körperliche Untersuchungen und Bildgewendeverfahren,
nach der ich alle Ergebnisse vorlegen habe,
werde ich Sie schrittfüllschürfen informieren, was Sie genau haben.
Machen Sie das alles heute Abend noch?
Wiederholen Sie bitte.
Machen Sie die Untersuchungen alles gleich heute Abend?
Ja, heute Abend.
Das dauert zuerst ein paar Stunden.
Dann würde ich Sie bitten, dass Sie vielleicht doch ein bisschen schneller arbeiten.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Aber machen Sie bitte keine Sorge, nehmen Sie einen Platz in der Untersuchungsschema.
Ich komme gleich.
Alles klar. Vielen Dank.
Ja, bitte sehr.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe einige Fragen.
Ja, bitte schön.
Zwei Fragen, Maximum.
Okay.
Okay, erste.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzseklaffon-Eis bis Senf?
Also in den letzten zwei Tagen schon sehr, sehr stark.
Ich würde sagen, so acht oder neun.
Acht oder neun, ja, sehr stark.
Okay, dann zweite.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Kann ich nicht sagen, wenn ich mir egal ob ich mich drehe oder so.
Dann machst du, das ist immer gleich, also immer gleich schlecht.
Sie meinen Dauer hat?
Ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay.
Noch andere Kollegen?
Eine Frage.
Haben Sie Zutrennen oder Aufstossen bemerkt?
Nein, nein, Zutrennen habe ich nicht.
Danke schön.
Stahlung?
Nein, nein, nein, Mustafa.
Nein, nein, nein.
Stahlung, aber ich vergesse schon.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Acht Fragen mindestens vergessen.
Bitte schön.
Also, haben Sie Ihr Sturrgang eine Farbe oder bemerkt?
Nein, ist alles in Ordnung. Nein.
Danke schön.
Eine Frage, bitte.
Bitte schön.
Wurden Sie verletzt oder hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Ja, gut.
Ah, nein, gute Frage, nein, ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt.
Ich bin auch nicht hingefallen und ja.
Ich habe eine Frage, bitte.
Bitte schön.
Ja, haben Sie etwas schweres Erhobern?
Ja, gute Frage.
Auch Erhobern.
Das ist schon ungefähr zwei Wochen her.
Auf dem Schwiff musste ich einige schwere Pakete umtragen.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, danach hat es angefangen.
Stimmt, ja.
Es hat immer zubenommen, richtig, ja.
Okay, danke.
Steinen die Schmerzen Ihrer Beine?
Nein.
Oder irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, wie gesagt, vom Rücken über die Rippen zu Brustchen, nach vorne.
Danke.
Wissen Sie, ob Sie gar Steine haben?
Vielleicht früher?
Ich weiß, es war vor vielen Jahren mal ein Ultraschalen gemacht worden.
Aber da habe ich keine Galenblasensteine gehabt, nein.
Seitdem war ich nicht, da habe ich jetzt keine Untersuchung.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestattet, aber eine Frage noch.
Sie haben gesagt, als ich besucht war,
und welche Diagnose wurde damals gestattet, ihre Hauses?
Jetzt vor zwei Wochen oder letztes Jahr?
Einmal, in der letzten Woche, ich habe gesagt,
Tramodol metamizol.
Ah, du hast gesagt, dass es in Rücken schmerzt, das geht vorbei.
Aber es ist noch schlimmer.
Keine Diagnose gestattet, nur Rücken schmerzt.
Sie meinten, dass es in Rücken schmerzt.
Welche Labore unterzutrücken oder andere unterzutrücken,
das geht vorbei.
Da hat keiner andere Untersuchung gemacht.
Ich werde die Fragen gestattet.
Können wir Arsatzgesprache anfangen?
Gerne.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Hallo, guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Unser neuer Kollege, Herr Grünis, die Sonne geht auf.
Sehr gut, bitte schön.
Dann erzählen Sie mal.
Ja, Herr Frank Büschler, 64 Jahre alt.
Er stellte sich bei uns seit einer Woche,
brennende, sehende,
rechtsseitige Toracalli vor.
Das ist immer noch Torachschmerzen, ne?
Ja, Torachschmerzen.
Er hat vor einigen Jahren ähnliche Bescheiden,
aber linken Seite Torachschmerzen gehabt.
Der Hausarzt hat ein Novalgin verschrieben,
aber es hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Der Schmerz liegt auf einer Schmerzschlacke bei 8 bis 9.
In der Vaggietative an Amnesien klagte er über Gewichtsunahme,
ungefähr 2 bis 3 kg in den letzten Jahren.
Nein, 2 oder 3 Jahre, deswegen müssen wir nicht sagen.
Das ist nicht vegetativ an Amnesien.
Das war unklar.
Unklar, ja.
Das werde ich noch mal in beiden Untersuchungen abklären.
Darüber hinaus leidet ein Nectury seit ungefähr 2 bis 3 Jahren.
Bei ihm ist der BPH Prostatehyperplazie festgestellt.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er an arteriellen Hypertonien
und Diabetes-Meditativs weiß seit ungefähr 10 Jahren.
Und Gonarthrose ungefähr seit 20 Jahren.
Medikamente, Namen und Dosierung sind unbekannt,
aber in der Untersuchung werde ich noch mal nachfragen.
Herr Büschler ist noch nie operiert worden.
Er ist nicht raucher, er trinkt selten Bier oder Wein.
Der Familienanamnese, sein 85-Jährige Vater,
leidet an arteriellen Hypertonien und Parkinson.
Und seine Mutter leidet an arteriellen Hypertonien und Diabetes.
Er ist einselkind, beheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Erwachsene kinder.
Beide Arbeit hat leidet viel Stress.
Bei ihm Polenallergie bekannt,
die sich mit Rhenokonjuktivitis äußert, er ist vollständig geimpft.
Das war es.
Okay, das ist ja eine sehr ausführliche Anamnese gewesen, Herr Doktor, vielen Dank.
Was vermuten Sie denn, was ist Ihre Arbeitstheagmose?
Es ist schwierig zu sagen, aber im Großen und Ganzen
denke ich an wegen der Risikofaktoren instabiler Angenepektores.
Okay.
Und differenzial durftnostisch, denke ich auch der TORAKAL-Nervkompressung.
Wie nennt sich das? Interkostalneuralgie?
Ja, vielen Dank für die Erinnerung.
Es könnte auch sein Ulcus, Peptic Ulcus, Gastricus oder dodenal Ulcus
wegen der Stress.
Ja.
Okay, was gibt es noch für Differenzialdiagnosen?
Woran denken Sie noch?
Rückenschmerzen, Ausstrahlung?
Ausstrahlung, auch Polycystolitis.
Angalblasesteine, klar, er hat rechtzeitig Oberbauchschmerzen,
klar, muss man auch denken.
Aber jetzt, was den Rücken angeht,
das kann doch im Rücken her noch sein.
Muskelspasm auch könnte sein.
Verspannung, okay.
Muskelverspannung, nicht eine Diagnose, nur Symptom.
Das ist richtig, wenn man das genau nimmt,
ist es ein Symptom, richtig.
Ankreatitis, von Rückenschmerzen her, Oberbauch,
könnte man daran denken, da muss man die Laborwerte mal machen,
das stimmt.
Das ist noch mehr an die Wirbelsäule.
Was kann an der Wirbelsäule sein?
Die Wirbelsäule könnte ein selbe Kale Disco Lapse sein.
Hat sein Bandschein vorfallen, richtig.
Nicht nur selbe Kale, vielleicht auch weiter tiefer.
An der Brustwirbelsäule BWK.
Ja, Torakale Disco Lapse, ja.
Woran muss man noch denken bei Wirbelkörpern mit solchen starken Schmerzen?
Ein Psyndolistesis oder Systolistesis,
oder was heißt denn?
Ja, ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht.
Spontylistesis, genau.
Spontylistesis, ja.
Aber ich denke immer weiter, was kann noch?
Denken Sie mal auch, was an Malignis.
Auch könnte sein ein Soster, Herr Versoster,
aber er hat gesagt, keine Hauteausschlag.
Wir haben auch keinen Ausschlag gesehen, das ist richtig.
Aber ich denke jetzt eigentlich immer noch an die Wirbelsäule.
Ja, genau, jetzt kam das Stichwort.
Ja, es könnte sein auch Torakale Fraktur.
Richtig, eine Fraktur, auch so, was wir denken.
Also eine Fraktur, woher kommt, also was ist die Ursache,
was kann für eine Fraktur an Wirbelkörper?
Ja, körperliche Belastung.
Ja, aber bei einem Mann, was kann es noch sein?
Ja, ist dann nicht, ja, osteoporose oder malinmetastasen?
Genau, immer auch an metastasen denken, richtig.
Es gibt ja viele Zumore, die in den Knochen metastasieren können.
Ich habe vor einigen Jahren eine Patientin, junge Patientin,
die war Ende 30, Anfang 40 gehabt, die kamen mit ähnlichen Beschwerden.
Rückenschmerzen, wir haben sie immer mit Rückenschmerzen behandelt.
Und irgendwann haben wir eine Computertomographie gemacht.
Auch multi-meerlome oder so.
Da hatte sie im Prinzip ein, genau, ein Miolok kann natürlich auch sein, klar.
Aber da hatte sie eine Buswirbelkörper-Fraktur.
Wegen der...
Das war eine metastase.
Und sie hatte, ich glaube, das war ein, bei ihr da ein Dickdam-Karzinon.
Dickdam-Karzinon, ein schlimmster Ursache.
Bei Männern muss man auch ein paar Arthrost-Heter-Karzinon denken.
Also wie gesagt, etwas Malignes, Wirbelkörper-Fraktur.
Daran muss man offenbar denken, wenn jemand mit solchen starken Schmerzen kommt
und die Medikamente schlagen nicht an.
Ja, super, sehr gut.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit der Patientin?
Was ist der letzte?
Ja, ich werde so als körperlicher Untersuchung,
Sensibilität, Untersuchung.
Und dann natürlich bildgebende Verfahren können wir auch
ein, zuerst Röntgen-Torax im Zweiten Ebenen veranlassen.
Und dann gehen wir dann, wenn es nötig,
Wirbelsäule MRT durch.
Immer, wenn meine Bandschale ausfließt.
Genau, sehr gut.
Was geben Sie für Medikamente?
Schmerzen?
Wir können auch den NSRA probieren, aber Norgen hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Muskel?
Muskelspasmlöse, das heißt Muskel-Relax-Tanz.
Körperschonung, natürlich sehr, sehr wichtig für ihm.
Lebensstilveränderungen, zum Beispiel Gewichtabnahme.
Ja, das ist eine langfristige Empfehlung.
Man muss der Akute erst mal seine Schmerzproblematik in den Bruch bekommen.
Genau, herausführen, wo die Ursache ist.
In der Akutsituation, sollen wir vielleicht ein Cortison-Schipitz verleihplachen?
Eventuell ja.
Sehr gut, vielen Dank.
Das war sehr gut, Herr Doktor.
Sie machen eine sehr schöne, übersichtliche Langsamwe.
Sie verstehen sie sehr gut.
Ich denke, sie werden gute Chancen haben, bei der Prüfung zu bestehen.
Ja, ich hoffe sehr.
Und dieser Fall, vielleicht war die Frage, was ist das jetzt?
Ich denke, das war eine interkostale Neuralgie.
So richtig zum Herzen hat es jetzt nicht gepasst.
Das war jetzt rechts-Toracal und nicht links-Toracal.
Er hat überwiegend Schmerzen, wenn man ihn an den Brustkorb berührt hat zwischen den Rippen.
Er hat Schmerzen, er hat dieses zum Teil brennende, das ausstrahlende direkt entlang der Rippen.
Und das kann vom Rückwärts.
Das hat eigentlich zur interkostalen Neuralgie gepasst.
Er hatte auch vorher etwas Schweres gehoben.
Und von daher würde man auch vielleicht eine Massage oder eine Manualiterapie anbieten,
eine Anwendung und vielleicht noch eine CT oder MRT-Untersuchung.
Ich bitte an Sie, Seine Jam.
Endlich können Sie uns diesen Patienten ein kurz vorstellen für Hauptbeschwerden.
Ich nochmal beschwer?
Ja, Sie.
Ich soll nochmal kurz vorstellen, was der Patient hat.
Herr Bücher ist, er kommt zu uns wegen...
Ach so, wie ich.
Ich kann gerne kurz noch eine Zusammenfassung der Patientenvorstellung machen.
Mich hätte es jetzt folgendermaßen vorgestellt.
Ein behaltbarer Patient.
Ja, Frank. 64.
Herr Frank Bücher, ein 64-jähriger Patient meldet sich mit pro-gredienten Schmerzen recht torrakal,
ausstrahlend vom Rücken nach ventral, mit ziehenden, brennenden Schmerzen,
verstärkt bei Bewegung, Atmung, also Bewegung und Atmung,
Schmerzresistent, keine Besserung unter bisheriger Schmerzmitikation mit Novalgien und Tramal.
Letztes Jahr ähnliche Beschwerden, links torrakal, was mit Ibuprofen damals gut behandelt wurde.
Der Patient hat keine gastrointerestinale Symptome wie Ebrechen, Durchfall,
Übelkeit oder Sodbrennen.
Parasilophys stabil, kein Fieber, keine B-Symptomatik.
Parasthesin?
Er hat leichte Hautparasthesin, genau, im Oberbauchbereich.
Genau, und ansonsten, unaufwendige Vorgeschichte, ohne malikene Erkrankungen
und ein metabolisches Syndrom mit Diabetes, Atelierhypothonion, Adipositas.
Dankeschön.
Vielen Dank.